we'll connect to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and black panther 2 is one of
coming Marvel installment far enough
into the future to be immune from
pandemic related delays new rock stars
has locked me up in this blue dungeon
and as a loner who prefers social
distancing even when the CDC doesn't
recommend it I'm spending this time much
like taskmaster obsessively watching
footage of Marvel films hoping to learn
survival tips and recently taskmasters
most surprising copycat move was in the
recent black widow trailer which
revealed black panther style vibranium
claws
Manolis definitely seemed to be
vibranium not just because those
extending kitty-cat claws themselves but
the gloves also appeared to be made from
these same vibranium weave that T'Challa
suit is and if you've been looking at
all this Black Widow promo footage
carefully there are actually a few clues
at all point to a possible secret what
kind of plot in this film setting the
stage for the second white panther film
in 2022 spoiler warning in case my
theories right but hey that only happens
like 55% of the time okay around the
time the Black Widow trailer dropped
Black Panthers Queen Ramona actress
Angela Bassett went on Jimmy Fallon and
humored mr. giggles with a tease for
Black Panther - was everything instead
of a black panther - by the way going
along you were telling me backstage if
they decided to change the costume of
Black Panther Jimmy Fallon always trying
to get a spoiler out of his guests but
unlike Maisie Williams Game of Thrones
April Fool's joke Angela Bassett is
having none of this [ __ ] was buried now
if true this confirmation brings up the
question why was black panther suit
changed it could just be that like Tony
Stark with his armor sharees vibranium
technology is ever-evolving
and since she upgraded the suit between
Civil War and Black Panthers she
probably has some new upgrades to force
us to buy new toys we've also learned
that each one of Tony Stark's armor
upgrades filmed a film were necessitated
by some failure or shortcoming of the
previous model the seamless nanobots
were applied to correct for the gaps in
Tony's armor that ant-man exploited in
civil war his nanotech stark gauntlet
and end game was developed so that the
nanobots could absorb the Infinity
stones off Thanos his hand into Tony
Stark
sorry the heaters and spider-mans suit
and homecoming were applied after Tony's
armor froze up during his first test
flight in the first Ironman now from
what I can tell there really isn't much
of a flaw in black panther's vibranium
suit I mean always room to improve like
you know not using full CG versions of
the suits in your movies final battle
but there is one big compromise coming
out of the first Black Panther film
secrecy black panther suit used to be a
stealth one who was designed to Leave No
Trace to be difficult to record by third
parties most of the world even the
Avengers were not aware of his existence
until a few years ago but now what
conda's most valuable defense mechanism
has been exposed for the whole world to
see and a Black Widow taskmaster has
some access to vibranium weaponry that
vibranium could have come from claws
stolen supply or we could be looking at
a leak from what Condon security now it
is important to note that Black Widow
will be set right after Civil Wars
sometime between 2016 and 2018 before
theta survived an infinity war that
timeline is roughly around the time that
the first Black Panther film is set that
film begins right when Zemo is being
incarcerated and features two challahs
returned home and ascendency the throne
after his father's death in civil war so
while seeking answers on how taskmaster
got that vibranium I spotted some
possible clues in the Black Widow
footage one of the red-room agents has
what looks like tribal scarring on her
cheeks like the kind we've seen on
people in Wakanda in that fancy room
that several of these agents are
associated with has a grid of what
looked like city maps my theory is that
taskmasters big plan is to deploy these
brainwashed agents to various world
capitals as part of a coordinated
assassination of world leaders including
the king of Wakanda with a sleeper cell
assassin embedded with the Dorma logic
we only have limited looks at what
conda's topography but it is enclosed by
a mountain range with an inner ring of
rivers and lakes some of the maps in the
Black Widow footage match that
topography that might be displaying
Wakanda now there remains another
unresolved mystery from Black Panther
back to its post-credit scene which
revealed Bucky recovering from his Civil
War injuries and brainwashing in in a
sort of rehab in Wakanda
white wolf also known as hunter is a
black panther adjacent character in the
Marvel Comics who ends up leading the
wakandans secret police and we never got
an answer as to why double comments are
giving Bucky this nickname
I mean I'd see why they'd call him
whitey but you know white wolf is a
moral thing and I think these kids know
that so how did Bucky get that white
wolf designation and how does it connect
to this mystery and Black Widow look
folks it's hard to know any of this
stuff for sure just like it's hard to
know if someone has a wallet in their
front pocket if it's so sleek and
discreet which by the way thanks to the
ridge for sponsoring this episode the
ridge makes everyday goods to a standard
you don't see everyday they streamline
your life by turning the things you
carry like backpacks like Chargers like
wallets into tools for a better living
their flagship product is the ridge
wallets was launched on Kickstarter in
2013 and now sits in the front pockets
of over half a million men and women my
wallet is to be full of pointless stuff
giving me back trouble but not anymore
this is their aluminum wallet in the raw
color now they do have other colors
including some very flashy Tiki designs
it's light it's strong and as a cool
industrial chic vibe the ridge is a
minimal front pocket wallet that's
designed to streamline what you carry
every day
it has 30,000 five-star reviews and is a
better way to carry your cash and cards
there's a lifetime warranty if you love
it three returns if you don't it comes
in titanium carbon fiber aluminum and
over a dozen different styles and colors
they also have great backpacks and
travel bags with RFID blocking pockets
and optional device charging batteries
get 10% off today with free worldwide
shipping in returns by going to Ridge
comm slash new rock stars
that's Ridge comm slash new rock stars
and user code new rock stars find the
link in the video's description
I think taskmasters stolen vibranium is
evidence of a plot involving one of his
Red Room agents targeting Wakanda and
T'Challa some time after the events of
Black Panther maybe late 2016 or 2017
but before the post-credits scene of
that film Bucky was in Wakanda
during this entire period and I think
the way he cleared his head and earned
the title of white wolf was by
intervening in that assassination plot
as a former brainwashed assassin himself
the Winter Soldier would know better
than anyone when a brainwashed assassin
is in their midst perhaps in a
post-credits scene to the Black Widow
film or a flashback in the Falcon in the
Winter Soldier we may see this secret
back story in which Bucky foils an
assassination and saves T'Challa slight
earning him the rank of White Wolf
head of Wakanda and secure
and intelligence and with wakanda's
sacred vibranium having leaks beyond its
borders Shuri will have to upgrade the
suit design and black panther to will
show us to chala in a new suit teamed up
with Bucky Barnes as a white wolf with
Bucky to party in an America that hates
him for a Wakanda that respects him
perhaps the latest wakandan security
breach these two will have to deal with
is the return of a former enemy who was
buried at sea kill monger
but his ocean burial interfering with
another hidden kingdom with a history of
conflict with Wakanda Atlantis with
Namor the Submariner being involved with
that underwater tremor Okoye brought up
an endgame you know reading on those
tremors it was a mild subduction under
the African plate do we have a visual
how are we handling it net it's a bit
quick under the ocean we handle it by
not handling it comment memo with your
theories our black panther - and a
special announcement for you guys we
don't know how long this a pandemic
related lockdown will last
but luckily since new rock stars is you
know pretty scrappy here we have a
limited crew hop-eration
it is literally me with a camera in a
blue space this pinch opportunity is
leading us back down memory lane we have
decided we will do an infinity saga
rewatch every MCU film hidden details
the real fun to find visual elements and
filmmaking tricks beyond you know the
more obvious comic book references that
we've already discussed in past videos
keep an eye out for updates on the
channel and ways that you can watch
along with us during this rewatch in our
official discord access our discord
today by becoming a patron of new
rockstars at patreon.com slash new
rockstars follow me i da boss follow new
rockstars and subscribed in your art
stars for breakdowns and everything
marvel thank you for watching bye
[Music]